We all love anime. Epic battles, heartbreaking
tragedy, hilarious comedy, and even some of the
most passionate love stories. And even if you’re
there just for the badass sword fights, don’t we
all love to see two long set-up characters
sharing a shy, but passionate first kiss?
The only thing is: There seems to
be absolutely no kissing in Anime.
Okay maybe some. But overall, I’ve caught
myself quite often getting frustrated that
two characters that CLEARLY have fallen for each
other, and have had a long romantic story line
together, never seem to end up giving us
the same satisfaction that Hollywood and
other western media can’t seem to make enough of.
So what’s the deal here Japan? Why is there such
a shortage of proper kissing scenes in Anime?
Hi, my name is Ohara and in this video we’ll
be exploring the cultural differences between
Japan and the rest of the West when it
comes to kissing and its role in Anime,
so that, you can start to enjoy & appreciate
all that Anime romance just a bit more.
We humans are absolutely
obsessed with kissing romance.
Romance & love are deeply routed in the
social part of our brains, that was crucial
for survival. You know, so we would actually
find someone to make some cute babies with,
instead of sitting on trees and scratching
balls the entire day. And so whenever we kiss,
or even watch someone else do it, our brains
literally bombard us with chemicals that trigger
these feelings of pleasure and anticipation,
particularly when it comes to a first kiss.
Even if it’s just on screen. And since anime has
become more and more popular in recent years,
it’s time to find out, why it’s refusing to give
us that sweet sweet dose of dopamine more often.
Now before we get into this, I want to make
clear that when I talk about anime I look at it
from a more mainstream perspective. I’m well aware
there are genres like romance anime, Seinen anime,
or Hentai , that have more kissing scenes in
them. And as always exceptions prove the rule.
But even there, it’s much much
less than you might expect.
And even if there is kissing it
often feels pretty damn awkward.
That being said, when I first sat down to think
about the REASON for this kissing shortage,
my fist thought was: It’s probably
gotta be the Mangakas right?
After all they write the story. And you can
actually find some pretty good arguments for this.
For example Shouen Anime in particular,
is traditionally aimed at young boys.
So maybe it’s seen as too girly? But then again,
Shounen has long outgrown this limitation.
With shows like Attack on Titan, Fullmetal
Alchemist or Shokugeki no Soma in the genre,
you can’t exactly say that these
are all made for a child-audience.
Actually MOST of them are probably not. Just look
at the broad audience a story like One Piece has,
across all ages and genders. Maybe
it’s the age of the CHARCTERS then?
But if they can hunt demons, overthrow governments
& commit mass murder, why can’t they make out?
So, while all this might play SOME role,
there must be something else. Something
BIGGER. Something that explains how this
phenomenon stretches so CONSISTENLY across
an otherwise so diverse medium. After all, we’re
all well-aware just how powerful and engaging
a well-written romantic plot-line with
a firey first kiss can be. Our historic
literature is full with it after all, reaching
thousands of years back to Homer and his Odysee
and even further. And it was right at this point,
that I made a breakthrough: The answer, I found,
lies not just within Anime and Manga,
but with Japanese culture itself.
Because, as it turns out, in Japan, that
has famously been isolated for large parts
of its history, kissing has not really been a
THING, until quite recently. If you know a bit
of Japanese or have watched enough anime, you’ll
probably know that the Japanese word for ‘Kiss’
is actually JUST the katakana word Kizu,
so simply copied over from English.
Now in fact there is a Japanase word for the
act itself dating back to the Edo-period,
that looks like this and literally
translates to mouth sucking. Ew.
Actually maybe not so ew after all. The catch
here however, is that this was simply considered
to be part of *** and not a separate concept
in itself. And so it took some more time until
kissing finally got its own specific word. And
by some more time, I mean the early 20th century.
The crux of all this is that kissing in
the classically romantic sense of the west
has only reached Japan very very recently.
And, as my Japanese friends confirmed when
I asked them about it, even though kissing
has been widely normalized today, it still
carries a bit of this sexual connotation, and
is considered to be a very intimate thing to do.
There actually is a related concept in Japan,
that I think explains pretty well how this
history influences the use of kissing in Anime.
PDA. Now you might or might not have heard this
term before. If you have. Congratulations, you
can put a cookie emote in the comments. However,
if you’re like me when I first moved to Japan
3 years ago and have absolutely no idea was
this means PDA stands for public display of
affection, and is not limited to just Japan.
With this phrase many East Asian countries
describe any sort of public physical contact
between two people who are attracted to
each other. This of course includes kissing,
but also supposedly ‘harmless’ things like hugging
or holding hands. While for westerners it’s pretty
normal, if admittedly at times a bit annoying to
see a couple go at it in public or simply cuddle
together, Japanese people tend to feel quite
uncomfortable about this stuff. It’s something
meant to be done in private. And this ALSO goes
for PDA on TV. And Anime is no exception here.
How then am I supposed to get any real romance
in these stories, you may rightfully ask.
The answer is, it’s already there. The
real secret to understanding romance and
relationships in Anime is to understand
how relationships tend to work in Japan.
In most western countries a
relationship often starts with a kiss,
which is why we love to see it so much in film.
Then the couple has time to get to know each other
better and form an emotional relationship
as well. The BIG cultural difference here,
is that Japanese relationships tend to work the
other way around. Two people start, you spend
a lot of time building a strong emotional bond
and learning what the other person is all about.
This emotional tension keeps building
until one formally confesses their feelings
and hopes for the best that the other person
return them. Once you have reached KISSING level,
the relationship usually has already reached
a pretty serious and intimate stage. Yes,
of course there are western couples who
date for a long time before ever kissing
and Japanese people who just like to
make out at a bar. But in general,
it’s undeniable that there is a fundamental
difference in the meaning of a kiss.
In other words, the reason that there seems
to be no kissing in anime is not because it’s
meant for kids or anything, but because kissing
plays a very different role in Japanese romance
than it does in the west. Now, thanks to
the internet and globalization in general,
this will surely change in the future - probably.
But for now, if you want to pick up on the
actually surprisingly intense romance in Anime,
no matter the genre, make sure to look for
these smaller gestures that mean so much
more to Japanese people. A flirty conversation,
a bump of the hand or watching a sunset together,
actually mean way more to these characters
and a Japanese audience than you might expect.
So next time you watch an anime
pay attention to these details,
instead of waiting for a hot, wet kiss. If
you really want that, watch some hentai.
Anyways. What other cultural differences
do you think play a role in Anime?
Let me know in the comments.
If you enjoyed this video,
a like is much appreciated and you can
click here to subscribe to the channel.
And last but no least here and here are more
of my videos. And you should click them or
smash your face into your phone screen with your
nose to watch them. Thanks for watching. Peace.